Ayer se anunció el acuerdo entre PSOE y sumar,
pero esto quiere decir que ya tenemos Nuevo gobierno,
pues yo la verdad es que no lo termino de ver tan
tan claro, porque no nos podemos olvidar
de que todavía
el PSOE necesita los votos
tanto de kerra como de jumps,
y claro, visto lo visto,
pues yo me planteo 2 escenarios
que creo que son los que se pueden estar dando,
por 1 lado puede ser que el PSOE
pues ya tenga los votos de jumps y de skerra,
aunque evidentemente pues cada 1 pues diga sus cosas,
cada 1 diga pues su discursito y demás,
pero internamente que ya lo tengan todo pactado
y pues ya sí que sí,
pues tengamos 1 acuerdo
y se sepa que VA a haber 1 Nuevo gobierno,
pero también por otro lado creo que puede ser
que esta escenificación
de peso y sumar con 1 pacto
diciendo exactamente las medidas que quieren hacer,
como lo de la reducción de la jornada,
etc. más que porque tengan 1 acuerdo de gobierno sea
pues entre otras cosas sí
buscando 1 acuerdo de gobierno,
pero también
pues enfocando hacia 1 posible campaña electoral,
porque claro, si al final el precio a pagar
con los partidos catalanes es excesivamente caro
y PSOE no quiere pagarlo,
pues siempre puede decir
que ellos ya tenían 1 acuerdo con sumar,
que estas son las medidas
que quieren implementar y que si los votas,
eso es lo que harán así Que nada,
lo que sí que yo tengo claro con todo esto
es que el futuro de nuestro país pues está en manos
de kerra y de Jones
y según lo que ellos decidan,
pues tendremos Nuevo gobierno
o habrá nuevas elecciones